hey guys it's Wednesday I'm Dan I'm Josh
and top against what news if like me
you're very specific and reoccurring
dream is to hunt the predator in Ghost
Recon wildlands you can do just that
right now not right now but this week
this week do it in your dreams with your
imagination the free jungle storm update
which is true out this week it's
introducing new cosmetics and a class
based on the movie with the big scary
clicky thing but who cares about
cosmetics when it also introduces a
limited-time mission where you can fight
the predator in single-player or online
co-op you might want a friend for this
one since the mission is supposed to be
the game's hardest fight the update is
designed to celebrate the 30 year
anniversary of the original movie if you
do kill off the big bag you'll get some
sweet loot like the predator mask which
comes with a predator vision mode and
the store will offer the predator pack
that includes a bunch of customization
items weapons and a new close combat
move the update also adds a new class
for ghosts war wildlands pvp mode the
class is inspired by Arnie's character
Dutch in the movie and what we don't
know a lot about it we do know the class
lets you in a battle rage mode wherein
you can create strategies and tactics on
the PvP battleground you'll need to have
the ghost world possible the season pass
to pick this one up though unless you
want to spend in-game prestige points
Bandai Namco has revealed three more
fighters joining the rusta for Dragon
both fighters just started out early so
I was surprised that's why my face
function all three of the new additions
hail from the Dragon Ball super series
if you don't know what that is it's
because it's the newest Dragon Ball
series and you stopped watching it like
10 years ago the latest issue of
Japanese magazine v-jump revealed that
beerus goku black and hid will all be
playable in the upcoming fighting game
beerus will be able to make the spheres
of destruction which explode on contact
and his special attack is god of
destructions judgment he will be able to
use his meteor special to temporarily
stop time and unleash a combo attack
while Goku black can summons a masseur
to bind an opponent the roster now
includes 24 characters v-jump also
revealed a new mode called come forth
Shenron where you collect Dragon Balls
after executing a number of combos once
you get all seven the eternal dragon
Shenron will appear and you can get one
of four wishes granted the other new
mechanic is dramatic production which
displays iconic scenes from the anime
before and after battle when players
meet certain conditions
dragon bullfighters is due out on
January 26 boy unknowns battlegrounds is
out on Xbox one and well it runs like
doesn't I do it is to say not great pop
g on xbox one might be the biggest game
launching is holiday for Microsoft's
console but it currently doesn't work
too well especially on the base Xbox one
and Xbox one s digital foundry has
performed a comprehensive amount of
tests and found the game to be a long
way from the PC version when loading in
digital foundry notes low resolution
textures combined with performance just
above or below 20 frames per second a
trip across the map in a buggy Jeep or
motorcycle can play flawlessly at 30
frames per second that is until another
player appears or you need to jump out
of the vehicle
exchanging fire with another player can
see the framerate dip again while there
are some improvements in the Xbox one X
version including high resolution
textures for the foliage draw distance
and certain improvements to frame rate
the performance is still wildly
inconsistent to be fair here pub G on PC
is also not exactly the most optimized
game out there for all of its issues on
console though pub G is perfectly
playable and enjoyable the game is still
in the Xbox game preview program and
develop a blue hole are working closely
with Microsoft on that versions
development
so hopefully improvements are on the
horizon zero dawn jared on that is
everything we've got for you today
thanks so much for joining us as always
I will be back same time tomorrow so be
sure to join us again then oh no what my
slave was rolled that we have to do it
all again
class based on the movie with the big
scary clicky thing but who cares about
cosmetics when it also introduces a
limited-time mission where you can get
sad with the monster with a face like my
ex-wife so that you'll be able to say it
later